Heading into the weekend, President Donald
Trump announced an upcoming new super duper
missile.
That is not my term.
That's his.
Asked.
Excuse me.
Asked about it, his press secretary, Kaley
McKenny, was saying she doesn't know anything
about it.
You got to go talk to the Pentagon.
So late last week, Donald Trump had an event
in the Oval Office to announce the space force
flag.
This is the newest sort of sub branch of the
military, not really a branch.
It encompasses the worst of nationalism, the
military industrial complex, unbridled capitalism
and Trump's delusions of grandeur all at once.
It puts all of those together.
There was a really funny moment when Trump
went over to take a picture with the space
force flag.
This is reality as far as we can tell.
And something weird happened.
The guy holding the flag sort of flinched
and almost dropped the flag.
Trump flinches.
It's all a comedy of errors.
It's very visual, I admit.
But let's take a look at it.
That's fantastic.
And so that was something.
But to get to the real disaster porn here
is Trump announcing the super duper missile,
incredible military equipment at a level that
nobody's ever seen before.
We have no choice.
We have to deal with the adversaries we have
out there.
We have to call it the super duper missile.
And I heard the other night 17 times faster
than what they have right now.
And you take the fastest missile we have right
now.
You've heard Russia has five times and China
is working on five or six times.
We have won 17 times.
And it's just gotten the go ahead 17 times
faster, if you can believe that.
General, that's something, right?
Sounds like we could we could really kill
a bunch of people at once with that thing.
I'm really, really exciting stuff.
So Trump says 17 times faster than what we
have right now.
So I believe that our fastest missile right
now is the bromo.
Also referred to as the P.J. 10.
That is a maximum speed of MOCH 3, meaning
about three times the speed of sound.
That's like 20, 300 miles per hour.
So 17 times faster than that.
Rough numbers.
That's Mach 51.
That would be about 39000 miles per hour.
That sounds weird.
I don't know about that.
About an hour later, Donald Trump's press
secretary, Kaley McKenny, was asked about
this.
The question alone was hilarious.
And here's her answer.
The president earlier in the Oval Office said
that the Pentagon was developing a, quote,
super duper missile.
Pentagon was asked about that shortly after
the president made his remarks.
He declined to comment to the White House.
So you can say what the president was describing.
Yeah, I was just referring back to the president,
Mark remarks in the Pentagon.
I don't have any new information on that at
this point.
So the Pentagon, as you heard there, referred
questions back to the White House.
White House said nothing.
They said go back to the Pentagon.
And eventually all that we got out of the
Pentagon was D.O.D. is working on developing
a range of hypersonic missiles.
No word on whether it's 17 times faster than
our current fastest missile.
Nick Schifrin from PBS NewsHour said Trump
maybe was referring to the AGM 183, which
is a hypersonic missile approved for purchase
by the Air Force in February.
So there's some obvious low hanging fruit
here like Trump.
Sounds like an idiot talking about a super
duper missile.
There's low hanging fruit in this may be classified.
Trump is again, maybe being irresponsible
with classified info.
That's nothing new.
The real story for me here is look at everything
that's going on and we're spending who knows
how much money on more new weapons that are
marginally better at killing more people more
quickly than what we have right now.
We still don't have enough corona virus testing.
We still don't have a national tracing initiative,
contact tracing initiative for the virus.
We have people who got twelve hundred bucks
and they're arguing about whether anybody
is going to even get anything else, although
it's starting to go in that direction.
It's the latest just disgusting enumeration
of our misguided priorities by the federal
government.
And as usual, another day, just another embarrassment
from Donald Trump, just a chorus of ridicule,
a barrage of embarrassment after this, once
again.